one of the most notable MCU projects to
deal with multiverses was Spider-Man no
way home which found Peter Parker and
Steven strange up against a sudden
influx of alternate reality bad guys and
different versions of Spider-Man that
event was so huge that it seems to have
caught Miguel O'Hara's attention in the
second official trailer for across the
spiderverse the race Heroes starts
ranting about the events of no way home
telling miles so don't even get me
started on Dr Strange and a little nerd
back on Earth 1999.99 so it seems like
Sony's animated world may be a part of
this larger fabric of spider universes
that includes Tom Holland Andrew
Garfield and Toby Maguire interesting
leaders does call a few things into
question in Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness it's made clear
that strange lives on Earth 616. however
O'Hara says strange lives on Earth 1999
which was the mcu's designation dating
back to a reference in 2008's official
Handbook of the Marvel Universe A to Z
volume 5.